what's going on guys this is rob and
today we are going to do something
different we're going to explain the
dweller in darkness from marvel comics
now for those of you guys who saw my
video on a history of the marvel
universe and we talked about how the
dweller in darkness was literally
responsible for the collapse of an
entire multiverse and the rebirth of all
things this video is going to sound
somewhat familiar at least in the
beginning but for those of you guys who
never saw that i don't know why because
honestly not to toot my own horn i think
i did a great job with that series
so the dweller darkness first appeared
in thor volume 1 issue number 229
technically his real first appearance of
marvel was with dr strange issue number
30 in 1978 but regardless of how you
slice it the dweller in darkness his
origin has never really been explained
in marvel comics and in fact the only
thing that we really get in terms of how
far back he goes regarding his
involvement with the affairs of humanity
his attempts to gain power comes with
adventures of the x-men issue number 12.
now this story basically detailed a
couple different things specifically it
was actually designed to bookend into
the old school thor origin of galactus
and expand on how all that happened and
how galactus actually became galactus
but also to give us a kind of an
explanation of why the previous
multiverse had collapsed in the first
place now of course we're talking about
the multiverse that existed before the
events of jonathan hickman's secret wars
in 2015 so i want to make sure we
eliminate any confusion there what we're
basically told in adventures of the
x-men issue number 12 is that the
dweller in darkness was a fearlord very
similar to nightmare and in fact while
they weren't really blood relatives
right blood relativity doesn't really
exist among the various lords of hell or
the fearlords or anybody like that uh
they were something akin to family right
insofar as like i'm a fear lord you're a
fearlord we're related through that
sense what the dweller in darkness had
done is that because it feeds on fear
and that fear bolsters its power it came
to that realization that if it destroyed
the entirety of the multiverse it would
scare the hell out of everybody and so
it did that what the dweller did is he
fractured the imcron crystal and the
emcron crystal itself being a kind of
hallway of doors for the multiverse
essentially turned into like a black
hole it started sucking in the entirety
of the multiverse itself now the goal of
the dweller in darkness was to feed on
all the fear that was let off by
basically everything across the
multiverse and that in doing so it would
basically be reborn in the new
multiverse with god-like power we're not
really told how his power would stand in
relation to somebody like the one above
all or the living tribunal or something
like that we're just told it was trying
to acquire a huge amount of power
ultimately the dweller in darkness was
defeated when the phoenix force in that
multiverse united the minds of everybody
in existence to basically calm them down
and so while the dweller in darkness was
stopped the destruction of the
multiverse could not be undone during
that time the space explorer gallon was
trying to figure out why his universe
was ending and while he never learned
anything about the dweller in darkness
and never got the actual answer for why
it was collapsing he was the last
surviving person in his universe he
merged with the sentience of his
universe and then coalesced in what was
the creation of the new multiverse and
that's why when the new multiverse was
born a version of galactus was put in
every single universe across the
multiverse now having said that in terms
of how the dweller in darkness survived
we're not really given an answer and in
truth i would say he didn't survive that
in fact whenever a new universe is born
that is born with all the things that
the universe has previously had
especially when it comes to the realm of
like dormammu the dark dimension
different things like that and of course
we have an explanation video at least i
think we have an explanation video on
dormammu which explains his role as part
of the foul team when he first arrived
in the dark dimension things like that
the important thing here is that what we
know is the dark dimension was initially
just a giant landmass in the old magic
comics we were told that like some kind
of an event happened that fractured the
dark dimension we were never really told
what that event was the result is that
it basically led to the creation of the
splinter realms and so while dormammu
ruled a huge section of the dark
dimension along with his sister umar
that the dweller in darkness nightmare
mephisto all those different people
basically settled and came into
existence based on those individual
locations now as far as how his origin
unfolds inside of the new multiverse as
it was created by marvel the dweller in
darkness is just the result of
humanity's fear that's all it is when
the first thing felt fear for the first
time the dweller in darkness began to
coalesce the more the things began to
feel fear with these sentient organisms
the more of a form the dweller in
darkness began to take until it gives us
his current form as it stands right now
and then from there his power just
expands based on the amount of fear that
things feel now in terms of his actual
involvement with regards to humanity
what we do know is that in doctor
strange sorcerer supreme number 33 we
were told that about 18 000 years before
the modern day essentially around the
time of the second celestial host when
the celestials arrived on earth and
basically caused the great cataclysm
right the sinking of atlantis the almost
complete obliteration of the deviants
the eternals fleeing from earth that the
dweller in darkness existed at that time
and while he was not necessarily
confined or required to stay within the
various fear dimensions that exist in
the splinter realms that what the
dweller in darkness did is that in order
to bolster its power it fed on the fear
that was generated by the wars between
the eternals the deviants and the humans
now something to understand here is that
at that point in time the deviants had
largely enslaved humanity and the
eternals would fight the deviants off
and on right but they all kind of had
this sort of circular fear of each other
the deviants were scared of the of the
eternals because of the power the
eternals had the eternals were scared of
the deviants because the deviants could
kill them humanity was scared of both
because they didn't fully understand and
all three were scared of the celestials
so it was quite literally just a giant
melting pot of fear this bolstered the
power of the dweller in darkness quite
significantly now ultimately again in
this doctor strange comic it led to the
arrival of a character by the name of
zered knock and this was basically a
sorceress that existed in the kingdom of
atlantis specifically the capital of
lumeria before it was sunk by the
celestials and zeratna had actually
learned of the dweller in darkness's
existence and the intention of the
dweller to continue feeding on that fear
and basically conquer the world and so
what ended up happening is zeradna
actually reached out to agamotto and
basically drew on some of the power of
the first sorcerer supreme and then
faced off against the dweller in
darkness now because the dweller is the
embodiment of fear technically he can't
really be killed the only way for the
dweller in darkness to cease to exist is
if nothing in the universe felt fear but
so long as something out there feels
fear that dweller in darkness will exist
and so the result of this is that
because the dweller couldn't truly be
destroyed instead it was locked inside
the the splinter realms in his own
feared dimension and just basically
confined there and so much like what
we've seen when it comes to a lot of
these powerful beings mephisto uh
cathone people like that there he's
always trying to find a way to escape
his dimension and then arrive on earth
and potentially expand his sphere of
influence out into the rest of existence
and seemingly conquer everything now
during this time and especially during
the great cataclysm right when the
celestial showed up on earth and
basically unleashed holy hell across the
world that because so many groups right
the the eternals the deviants humanity
because they felt so powerless in the
face of the dweller in darkness they
began to give in to despair and what
this did is it actually allowed the
dweller in darkness to create a son if
you want to call him who's actually
called despair and that guy would
actually become incredibly important
later on but again you kind of fast
forward over the years the dweller in
darkness doesn't really show up a whole
lot he just kind of shows up you know
periodically for example in thor issue
number 229 and 230 that the dweller in
darkness kind of operating behind the
scenes had actually began to sort of
manipulate a few people and actually
promised them that if they died they
would continue to live on forever and
this allowed these individuals to
essentially become thralls of the
dweller in darkness actually engaging in
different campaigns across the world
that would ensure a kind of gain of his
power for example mr fear one of the old
school characters of marvel who
developed a fear toxin similar to what
the scarecrow did in dc comics was
influenced by the dweller in darkness
and that by creating that fear toxin he
could bolster the feelings of fear in
others which would kind of imbue and
power the dweller in darkness even more
and so all this came to a head in dr
strange sorcerer supreme in issues 31
running all the way up to issue number
40. it was a pretty significant story
and the way this played out was in two
forms the first was a gathering of fear
and the second one was called the great
fear and the whole idea behind this is
that the dweller in darkness sought to
use or sought to make an alliance with
the other fearlords specifically
nightmare for the purpose of enabling
him to basically conquer the world the
biggest issue that happened with this is
the other fearlords are always vying to
do the same thing and so in reality the
whole thought process of nightmare is
why would i help you conquer the world
if that's what i want to do
and so of course nightmare and a lot of
the other other fearlords ended up
turning against him now in doctor
strange sorcerer supreme issues 38
through 40 what ended up happening is
the dweller in darkness had actually
abandoned his quest to be involved with
the more powerful fearlords and actually
grabbed some of the smaller fearlords
and during this time he actually ended
up invading earth right launching an
attack against the planet and feeding on
the fear of a ton of people bolstering
his powers but during this time his son
despair had actually approached
nightmare and essentially made nightmare
aware of the plans of what the dweller
in darkness was doing and so this led to
a huge fight between the two the biggest
problem with this and it was actually a
great scheme by despair is that because
the the fight between nightmare and the
dweller in darkness was so extreme they
were both emanating fear and their
influence was affecting humanity so
humanity was becoming just riddled with
fear right they were absolutely
horrified but the more humanity became
fearful the more they began to give into
despair and ultimately that empowered
despair to the point that he was
actually more powerful than both the
dweller in darkness and nightmare now
ultimately despair was defeated by the
combined efforts of doctor strange and
various other individuals and so because
of that the dweller in darkness ended up
just kind of slinking back to his fear
dimension despair was you know was kind
of the end of him nightmare were taken
off as soon as things started popping
off so the event came to an end pretty
quickly following that you never really
saw anything from the dweller in
darkness the only things you really saw
that happened were doing like the old
journey into mystery comics as part of
fear itself right so issues number 633
636 645 these are basically stories that
dealt with the idea of the dweller in
darkness potentially using what was
going on with regards to the serpent the
long-lost brother of odin trying to
conquer the world using the fear
generated during the events of fear
itself as a way to bolster his power but
ultimately it all kind of came down to
nightmare who actually was able to
utilize that fear more effectively than
the dweller in darkness could and that's
all you really get right i mean this
kind of wraps it up the dweller in
darkness is a character who's almost
never appeared in marvel comics outside
of the fact that he belongs to a
dimension called ever and i we don't
really know anything about him we
suddenly just know he's a fearlord he
feeds on the fears of humanity he's
almost succeeded in conquering the world
a couple times but was usually defeated
through a combination of his own
offspring despair somebody like
nightmare or doctor strange and clea and
that was it that's really all you got so
i apologize if this is not necessarily
up to par with regards to our normal
videos explaining characters
but this guy just isn't quite on the
same level as a lot of the characters
that we do discuss so there's just not a
whole lot of stuff to bring to the table
here but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end thank you
guys for watching and i will catch you
all later
peace